in his first press conference in months
joe biden celebrates his successes
questions election integrity and gives
the green light to vladimir putin to
invade ukraine so things are going great
i'm ben shapiro this is the bench bureau
show
today's show is sponsored by expressvpn
protect your data from bigtech with a
vpn i trust visit expressvpn.com
ben we'll get to all the news in just
one moment first did you know that you
don't just vote every november you vote
every single month with the money that
you are spending because a lot of the
corporations you give your money to
they're spending that money on
politicians you don't like this is true
for verizon a t t-mobile you might be
funding joe biden or nancy pelosi or
chuck schumer or any part of their
agenda instead why not switch over to
pure talk see pure talk uses the exact
same tower same 5g network as one of
those big companies but with the peace
of mind that you are supporting a
veteran run business a business whose
employees are right here in the united
states so yes this is one monthly bill
you can be proud to pay oh and by the
way it's going to cost you like half of
what your current cell phone bill is the
average family saves over 800 a year so
head on over to puretalk.com find the
plan that is right for you then find the
phone that's right for you or just bring
your own and then because they love my
listeners in particular enter promo code
ben shapiro and you will save 50 off
your very first month of coverage that
is puretalk.com promo code ben shapiro
to save 50
off your first month of coverage plus
hundreds of dollars down the road and
spend your money with a company that
doesn't hit your guts head on over to
puretalk right now puretalk.com promo
code ben shapiro to get started okay so
joe biden is absolutely flailing we had
a poll last week quinnipiac suggesting
that his approval rating was down to 33
well now we have a second poll from
civics suggesting that his approval
rating is at 34 so this makes two
straight polls in which joe biden is in
the low 30s these are abysmal numbers if
you are the president of the united
states and this follows hard on a
morning console politico poll
that shows that only 11 of americans
after one year give joe biden in a grade
as president of the united states and
only another 20 give him a b which means
that 69 of americans say that joe biden
is a sea or below president including 37
of americans who say that he's got an f
so this guy is a fail he is a giant fail
and as we discussed yesterday he's
failing on every front well the biden
administration because they have no
capacity to shift gears they are not
clintonian joe biden is not bill clinton
he's not a talented politician like
barack obama he he's nothing he's a big
nothing burger of a human and he's been
a nothing burger of a human since he
entered the senate and was quickly seen
to be a bloviating bag of plagiarism
ever since then the president of the
united states has had a really tough
time shifting gears he is not somebody
who shifts and moves quickly he is
somebody who sort of bobs atop the
eddies of political life he's not a
leader he's not somebody who is going to
forcibly move forward his agenda he is
just a guy who happens to be kind of
dead center of where they're where the
democratic party is at any given point
and and that means that he he does not
have the capacity to change course he
cannot do it
and and so when his administration
basically said you know what we've got a
comms problem here and this was the
story over the last few days we need to
shift comms right whenever a politician
says and when they start leaking stories
to the press about how they are going to
shift communication strategy
you know that this politician is a
failure when they say they're going to
shift political strategy you know that
the politician might actually be capable
of changing
but when they're refusing to change any
of their political strategies they're
just going to shift how they talk to
people forget it because politicians are
what they are i've yet to see a
politician who's capable of of really
shifting what they are well what made
bill clinton very effective is that bill
clinton was
incredibly malleable as a politician
one day he could be conservative one day
he could be far left
but his mannerisms were not particularly
malleable right he just had broad range
as an actor bill clinton had broad range
right sometimes he was crying in front
of camera denying things and the next
day he was crying apologizing for the
same things sometimes he was doing
jovial bill clinton sometimes he was
doing sad and empathetic bill clinton he
had a lot of range barack obama didn't
have a lot of range but he had a lot of
charisma joe biden has neither ranged
nor charisma and so when his team says
we need to get you out in front of the
cameras more
the first reaction for anyone smart
inside the white house should have been
no we don't
no we don't this guy became president
literally because he did not get in
front of cameras it is amazing how many
politicians think they are popular
because people like them as opposed to
being popular because people hate their
opponents
politics is oppositional by nature and
people do not love joe biden and they
certainly don't love him after what he
did in afghanistan which is when his
polls really tanked okay so yesterday
joe biden decides i need to save this
presidency it's time to save the
presidency i'm going to do a press
conference
at this point jen saki started drinking
heavily
gensake picked the wrong way to stop
sniffing glue man so joe biden decides
he's going to hold his first presser in
months and for all of those wondering
why joe biden doesn't do press
conferences this would be the reason the
man went on for two long interminable
hours
he started babbling nonsensically
he started stepping all over his own you
know what
he he is not capable this is not a
capable competent coherent president he
is not
so
this whole thing opens with him being
asked by zeke miller from the associated
press about whether he over-promised
when he entered office because he said
he was going to shut down the virus and
he was going to create a booming economy
he's going to bring world peace all the
rest of it and joe biden's answer was of
course defensive because joe biden is a
defensive nasty person this has been
true in the senate forever it was true
on the campaign trail he literally said
on the campaign trail to a detractor a
bernie sanders fan detractor he
literally said look fat
to the guy i mean that's who joe biden
is so he does that with a reporter here
did you over promise to the american
public what you could achieve in your
first year in office and how do you plan
to course correct going forward why are
you such an optimist
look
i didn't over promise
and but i have probably uh
outperformed what anybody thought would
happen
the fact of the matter is that
we're in a situation where
we have
made enormous progress
he said he's outperformed expectations
unless those expectations were that he
would have a zero percent approval
rating he has not outperformed
expectations this is a person whose
delta between high approval rating and
low approval rating is about 16 percent
he went from about 50 54 more than that
almost 20 percent he's down from about
54 all the way down to low 30s according
to some of these polls
that's a huge delta
so no and one of the reasons is because
he's absolutely incoherent
so yesterday i mean it's it's hard to
watch these press conferences with joe
biden because
you you do feel in real time that you
may be watching the last joe biden press
conference you feel like he might
actually physically keel over his brain
just stops functioning in the middle of
these
in the middle of these exchanges
it's incredible right he he's just
incoherent
so here is a here is joe biden
rambling and then going silent talking
about talking about the voters the voter
who
is just trying to figure out as i said
how to take care of their family put
three squares on the table stay safe be
able to pay their mortgage or their rent
etc
uh
has is becoming
much more informed on
the
the motives of
some of the political
players and some of the uh
and the political parties
it's all fine
this is fine dog dot jiff
dog in fiery room
you know i used to live in boston for
three years when i was in law school and
uh being from a very warm climb i was
not used to the icy conditions and so i
remember one time i went over to the
local kosher grocery store to pick up
some food and like an idiot i parked on
the ice i didn't know anything so i
parked down the ice so i get back in the
car and i start trying to gun the engine
to to you know actually move the car and
the car's going nowhere the wheels are
just spinning and spinning and spinning
and spinning
that is joe biden's brain right now it's
just spinning and it's going nowhere
there's no traction there
he is not with us this is a president
who is not with us and so he's asked you
know um some people question your mental
fitness he's like
right come on man
why do you suppose
such large segments of the american
electorate
have come to harbor
such profound concerns
about your cognitive fitness thank you i
have no idea
yeah i'm sure he doesn't i am sure he
doesn't the good news about a press
conference this bad for joe biden is
that he doesn't remember it even now
within five minutes it was gone from his
brain
okay also i mean again i can just show
you clip after clip from this press
conference just play over and over of
joe biden completely falling apart
there's a point where he said i mean
he's going to ask a rhetorical question
no he won't by the way his dead giveaway
in terms of body language is him
clutching
his portfolio
he's got this portfolio that usually
sits on the deck he starts clutching it
defensively almost it's bizarre
i don't think there's been much
on any incoming presence plate that's
been a bigger menu than the plate i had
given to me i'm not complaining knew
that running in
and the fact of the matter is we got an
awful lot done
an awful lot done
and there's more to get done but look
let's
let me ask a rhetorical question
no i won't anyway
what is going on
what is going on and then just kind of
clutching his portfolio that what is
happening what's happening
then he's asked about the polls and and
question who said it donald trump or joe
biden fake news fake pose
it was really bad when trump said it
right trump wasn't allowed to doubt
polls but joe biden does it all the time
here we go
how do you plan to win back moderates
and independents who cast a ballot for
you in 2020 but polls indicate aren't
happy with the way you're doing your job
now i don't believe the pulse oh he
doesn't believe the polls so i guess
they don't exist anymore that's not he's
not casting aspersions to the press he
just doesn't believe the polls and good
news for democrats this
geriatric doddard is going to be heavily
involved in the midterms he says
congratulations to all you democrats in
purple district and i hope that you have
a nice lobbying job lined up because man
it ain't going to go great
i'm going to be deeply involved
in the off these off your elections
uh-oh we're going to be raising a lot of
money we're going to be out there making
sure that we're helping all of those
candidates and scores have already asked
me to come in and campaign with them to
go out and make the case
in plain simple language as to what it
is we've done what we want to do and why
we think it's important now for all
those battleground
for all this battleground congress
people and senators it's time to break
out that sad trombone from the price is
right
it's joe biden
joe biden jet setting into your
territory is probably your worst
nightmare right you're running a
competitive race and here comes an
incoherent
and
he he just he's got nothing and that
guy's going to jet in and he's going to
fix your race good luck with that on
topic on topic after topic yesterday joe
biden just crapped the bed i mean he
just made a mess and jen saki who's the
night nurse of the white house she had
to try and fix some of these things but
again jensaki picked the wrong week to
stop doing math this is this is not the
right week for that we'll get to more of
this in just one second first
even though you are far from ordinary
the truth is that erectile dysfunction
is really common in fact 52 of dudes
aged 40 to 70 experience some form of ed
head on over to getroman.com right now
speak to a u.s licensed healthcare
professional about ed get 15 bucks off
your first month of treatment roman
ready is confidence personified it means
that everything is working the way that
it is supposed to when you need it to
with roman you get a free online
evaluation ongoing care for erectile
dysfunction all from the comfort and
privacy of your home a us licensed
healthcare professional will work with
you to find the best treatment plan if
medication is appropriate it ships you
free with two-day shipping the whole
process is straightforward convenient
and discreet getting started is simple
just go to getroman.com complete an
online visit today take care of your ed
without leaving your home complete that
online visit today connect with the us
licensed healthcare professional and get
it taken care of head on over to
getroman.com
if you're prescribed get 15 bucks off
your first month of ed treatment make
sure you're ready to have confidence and
control this season roman ready again
head on over to getroman.com ben if
you're prescribed get 15 bucks off your
very first month of ed treatment okay so
then joe biden got into the topics and
on topic after topic he was just a
disaster area so
the the economy right now is flaming out
it is stagnating yesterday the nasdaq
fell more than one percent to enter in
correction territory according to the
wall street journal
it showed
166.64 points or 1.1 percent it finished
the day 10 below its all-time closing
high set back in november at a client of
greater than 10 is considered a
correction for a stock index right it's
not a temporary decline it's now a
correction wednesday's trading activity
continued a tumultuous stretch for major
indices with stocks pairing their
earlier gains and closing near session
loads in the first week of january many
investors have started dumping shares of
tech companies and piling into other
corners of the market in anticipation of
rising interest rates and of course the
fed has been talking about tapering and
increasing the interest rates because of
the inflation that they helped create
last year and that joe biden's fiscal
and monetary policy have generated
so joe biden was asked some questions
about the economy at this particular
press conference he said he is not going
to scale back any of his big spending
plans man it
this guy thelma and louise is that just
thumb and louise headed for the cliff
they're off the cliff it's the end of
the movie already see the thing about
them and louise the end of that movie is
that if that movie goes on for another
32 seconds
it gets extremely grisly
okay and uh the biden administration is
the is the 32 seconds of thumb and
louise that was never put on film
you are only guaranteed control of
washington for one more year before the
midterms do you need to be more
realistic and scale down these
priorities in order to get something
passed
no i don't think so when you say more
realistic i think it's extremely
realistic to say to people
because let me back up
let me back up let him back up yeah you
got to back up dude because he ain't got
nothing
as we'll talk about in a little while
all of his plans are dead this
presidency is effectively over he loses
congress in 2022 he doesn't have control
of congress now
he got done what he's gonna get done
namely the infrastructure bill that's it
those are all the things he got done he
got done his crappy bailout plan his 1.9
trillion dollar boondoggle spending plan
on purely partisan lines he got that
done
and then he got done through
reconciliation and then he got done
his bipartisan infrastructure plan those
are the two things he got done he got
nothing else done oh yeah also he
surrendered in afghanistan created a
40-year high in inflation and completely
tanked
the the supply chain so a few things a
few things here is joe biden trying to
explain about the inflation it's not his
fault it's everybody else's fault of
course
the inflation has everything to do with
the supply chain
and
i think what you're seeing is that
we've been able to make
progress on speeding up
the access to
materials uh for for example
one-third
of the car of the uh
increase in cost of living is the cost
of automobiles
the reason automobiles have skyrocketed
in price is because of lack of computer
chips
okay um dude your monetary and fiscal
policy have generated this inflation
yes we have a supply chain problem that
supply chain problem has been wildly
exacerba exacerbated by all of your
policies you've created labor shortages
you can't talk to a business person in
america right now who's not experiencing
labor shortages the prices on
fundamental goods have risen
exorbitantly if you're running a
restaurant right now you're paying like
twice what you were a year ago for goods
that you need in order to generate the
food for your restaurant
that is joe biden's fault
he's got no ability to hem that in this
is why he has to rely on the federal
reserve to hammer it and he says he's
not going to scale anything down i mean
it's amazing i'm not going to scale back
any of my spending plans also inflation
isn't my fault okay and then there's
kovit so remember this president came
into office saying that he was going to
destroy covet
no
no it's just getting worse and worse
from this administration and this is the
amazing thing folks we now have the data
the data are absolutely clear if you
have had covet already you are really
really safe from kovid when you get it
again you're not getting hospitalized
you ain't dying and that is the data the
new york times reported it today
if you are a person who was reinfected
with covid after having had alpha you
got delta
your rate of hospitalization was 0.3 if
you're a person vaccinated and you got
delta your rate of hospitalization was
0.7
according to the new york times
okay which means that omicron which is
hitting every single human including
people who are triple vaxxed i know
people who are triple ducks who have
gotten omicron
those people are now extremely safe in
fact they're pretty safe after the facts
and yet joe biden simply can't stop this
he can't he has to continue because he
lets the paranoid loonies in his party
run everything
and it has become an absolute mental
condition this is a mental condition for
people people who are running around
paranoid about covet
after having been vax
with omicron being the dominant strain
which is killing
something like 90
fewer people
according to kaiser permanente than
delta
if you're still a person running around
in a state of wild paranoia
there's some you have a problem and you
need to think about that problem
joe biden has a problem because those
are the people running his
administration so here he is saying that
he's not just going to you know allow us
all to go back to regular life no we
can't do that because covet won't let us
do it
the covet 19 is not going to give up and
accept things uh you know it's just it's
not going to go away
immediately but i'm not going to give up
and accept things as they are now
some people may call what's happening
now the new normal i call it a job not
yet finished okay then whose fault is
that we'll get better
we're moving toward a time and covet 19
won't disrupt our daily lives okay uh
down here in florida let me tell you a
story joe down here in florida it ain't
been disrupting our daily lives for like
a year
well we're all back to normal we've been
back to normal for quite a while and i i
will say it is unbelievable i was
talking to a friend from california and
this friend tends to be a little bit
more on the paranoid side and people who
have been spending this entire pandemic
in california new york or jews and new
jersey
connecticut right any place that's very
locked down
those people have such a different view
of the world than people who have been
living in free states but joe biden is
governed by new york and new jersey and
california so he can't let it go he just
can't
he just has to downplay things also like
the bad effects of his own policies so
he's asked about schools closing because
there are certain schools that are
reclosing there's not a single school in
america that should be closed because of
omicron not one
not a single one
number one if people get omicron they're
gonna be fine as a general rule you're
going to be fine if you get omicron if
you're vax you're certainly going to be
fine if you had a prior infection you're
almost certainly going to be fine right
this is just the way this works
and yet joe biden is saying that you
know if school's shut it's not that big
a deal because there aren't that many
why are you shutting schools at all
children have not been dying in large
numbers from this pandemic the entire
time
that is particularly true of omicron
i know because all three of my kids got
it in the last two weeks they're all
fine
it's extraordinarily transmissible and
it is very not deadly and shutting down
schools is idiotic but here's joe biden
down playing this it's
here here we go
what can your administration do to help
make up for learning loss for students
first of all i put in perspective the
question you asked
very few schools are closing so it means
are still open
so you all phrase the questions when
people i don't think it's deliberate on
your part but your phrase the question
of anyone watching this on television my
god there must be all those schools must
be closing what are we going to do
are still open
man when he does the creepy serial
killer whisper into the microphone uh it
is not a good look
geriatric man the 95
are still open come into the sewer i
have a red balloon
reporter
yes
um so uh quick note here they're about
99 000 public schools in the united
states about 99 000 and a lot more
including private schools let's say five
percent are shut down
that's like five six thousand schools
that's tens of thousands of students who
can't go to class
and even the ones who are going to class
right now are going to class masked
they're going to class masks they can't
understand their teachers they can't
interact with other children the way
that normal children are supposed to
interact they're crippling an entire
generation
based on nothing based on garbage data
the people who are still insisting on
masking kids are operating on the basis
of zero data zero they cannot provide
any evidence by the way this is why the
uk never masked kids under the age of
12. and now the uk has just announced
they're not asking anybody all the
masking rules in the uk are over all the
work rules in the uk are over you have
an incoherent babbling man
who says that the economy is fine and he
wants to spend more money and also that
he's not going to leave you alone about
covid that was the least controversial
segment of what he had to say yesterday
we'll get to the most controversial
stuff that he said at this presser
yesterday because this guy man he's
going to tank his there will be people
not yet born who don't like joe biden i
mean we are talking about generational
lows in terms of presidential approval
rating from a guy who entered office
with a 56 approval rating 54 it's
amazing
first let's talk about the fact that
this should be a good year for a lot of
businesses because we should be in a
normal economic recovery actually with
the greatest economic recovery from an
artificially induced economic coma in
american history but some industries are
projected to grow even more than normal
and it includes like pet services
fitness for example home improvement
if you work for or own a business in one
of these growing industries or a wide
range of other industries you probably
need to hire asap i've talked to so many
business owners who need to hire and
they're having a problem finding people
well there's only one place to go zip
recruiter right now you can try zip
recruiter for free at ziprecruiter.com
dailywire zip recruiter uses powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job that
encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip recruiter is the number one
rated hiring site in the united states
based on g2 ratings zip recruiters
technology is so effective that four out
of five employers who post unzip
recruiter get a quality candidate within
the very first day right now try
ziprecruiter for free at this exclusive
web address ziprecruiter.com dailywire
at ziprecruiter.com
d-a-i-l-y-w-i-r-e zip recruiter the
smartest way to hire all right so now we
get to the really controversial segment
right this is amazing so we've only gone
through the part where joe biden
basically
his brain stops working we got through
the part where joe biden says that he's
not going to scale down any of his
spending plans and where he blames all
of the inflation on the supply chain
problems and where he says that he's
just going to continue cramming down
bizarre vax policies on the rest of
america that's not the most
controversial part then we get to
elections so
we've spent the last two years saying
that the worst thing you can do in
american politics is challenge the
veracity of elections you can't do it
right donald trump is a very bad man
because he said that the 2020 election
was stolen via election fraud that was a
danger to democracy that was undermining
faith in our electoral system how could
anyone do this it would be the worst
thing in the world if anyone did this i
mean if stacey abrams does it that's
different but if donald trump does it
it's the worst thing that ever happened
donald trump undermined american
democracy and this made him a
historically evil human
so yesterday
joe biden was asked a pretty simple
question joe you've been going around to
places like georgia and suggesting that
there is widespread voter suppression
that republicans all over the united
states are attempting to rig the vote by
rigging who counts the vote you have
suggested that if republicans
do not pass your federalization of all
election procedures bills then this
means that elections will not be fair
and free
so
are you suggesting that elections are
illegitimate if you don't get what you
want here here is joe biden just saying
elections are illegitimate if i don't
get what i want
speaking of voting rights legislation if
this isn't passed do you still believe
the upcoming election will be fairly
conducted and its results will be
legitimate
well it all depends on uh
whether or not
we're able to
make
the case to the american people that
some of this is being set up to try to
alter the outcome of the election
this is amazing it was amazing so he's
asked if you don't get your bill are you
saying that the next election won't be
fair
and joe biden is basically saying yes i
think the next election will not be fair
he is preemptively doubting every
election in the united states because
guess what there are 50 states they all
different election procedures but he's
saying if i don't pass this federal bill
that by the way failed last night in the
senate if that doesn't pass future
elections are in doubt we cannot trust
them any longer
so you might think that was a gaffe
right maybe maybe listen he's incoherent
he babbles he talks to walls
he he
sounds like a man who is heavily stoned
so maybe just maybe he doesn't know what
he's saying
no he knows exactly what he's saying
he's asked the same question again and
here he goes doubling down on it do you
think that
they would in any way be illegitimate
oh yeah i think it's easy to
be illegitimate imagine
imagine if in fact trump has succeeded
in convincing pence to not count the
votes
imagine if
in regards to 2022 sir 2052 i mean
those
attempts to say that
the count was not legit you have to
recount it and we're not going to count
we're going to discard the following
votes i mean sure
it i'm not saying it's going to be legit
it's the increase in the prospect of
being illegitimate is a direct
proportion of us not being able to get
these
these reforms passed that's unbelievable
it's the last statement where he says
the increase in the chance of
illegitimacy is directly proportional to
me getting what i want
this man is saying that elections in the
united states are no longer trustworthy
you can't trust elections because he's
not getting what he wants so that means
you can't trust elections anymore so i
don't want to hear any more from the
left i don't want to hear any more from
the democratic party about donald trump
undermining democracy when you're
unifying moderate president of the
united states comes out and says in a
press conference twice that future
elections are illegitimate unless he
passes a bill that just failed
he's just undermined democracy he is
setting the stage for violence folks
if the idea is that donald trump set the
stage for violence by raising the
temperature
that donald trump spent a month and a
half two months suggesting that the
election of 2020 was illegitimate and
that led to january 6th if that's the
contention of the left what does it lead
to when the president of the united
states says that not just one election
every election in the united states is
on the border line of legitimacy because
he's not getting what he wants
this means effectively speaking there's
no one who believes that if they lose it
might be because they just lost
that's an amazing thing it's incredible
and we'll see how the media cover it
there are a few people who noted it by
the way john king on cnn last night he's
like didn't he just stay out the
veracity of elections dana bash on cnn
she's like that sounds like not great
that sounds kind of trumpy right but but
most of the media is just gonna be well
no it's different it's different john
harwood say well it's different now
trump he was doubting elections because
of election fraud joe biden he's
doubting elections because republicans
are trying to steal elections no it's
the same thing guys
the minute you suggest that voter
verification procedures somehow mean
that elections are illegitimate it means
that you only accept elections when you
win that's what joe biden is doing right
there
okay then joe biden was asked about the
line that he's been trotting out
recently over the past year
that everybody who opposes his voting
agenda is a jim crow racist and joe
biden gets angry he starts shouting at
clouds because he's old man grandpa
simpson shouting at clouds
listen to his defense
of his own words
he he's asked about
saying in georgia that you have to
choose to be on the side of martin
luther king or on the side of bull
connor you have to choose between being
on the side of jefferson davis or being
on the side of abraham lincoln that's
what he said so he is comparing without
a doubt the people who do not side with
him to people who would have sided with
bull connor and jefferson davis and
george wallace
so he's asked about that and here is his
his angry defensive ridiculous response
i know that you dispute the
characterization that you called folks
who would oppose those voting bills um
as being bull connor or george wallace
but you said that they would be sort of
in the same camp no i didn't say that
look what i said go back and read what i
said
and tell me
if you think i called
anyone who voted on the side of the
position taken by bull connor that they
were bull connor
and that is an interesting reading of
english you you i assume you got into in
the journals because you like to write
um okay so it's philip blegman of real
clear news
and
what he is asking joe biden i mean even
jordan's defense makes no sense he's
like are you saying are you
are you saying that you know
interesting reading
of english
which is a language i sometimes talk in
are you
that go back
and read it
and then you know when i say
that anybody who's on the side of bull
connor are you saying i'm saying they're
like book yes that's exactly what you
said that's exactly what you said
it was one of the worst things i've ever
heard a president say it's amazing even
his own party even his own party was
like that was too much joe and he's like
no no that's not what i said at all of
course that's what you said
of course that is what you said
i mean the insanity of him
saying anything being quoted on the
thing
and then suggesting that he never said
the thing is truly unbelievable
he said i did not say they were going to
be a george wallace or a bill connor i
said we're going to have a decision in
history that is going to be marked just
like it was then you either voted on the
side that didn't make you george wallace
or it didn't make you bull connor but if
you did not vote for the voting rights
act back then you were voting with those
who agreed with bull connor so you're
not you know you're not like bull connor
you're just like those people who are on
bull conor's side oh thanks
so if i say in a speech that joe biden
you know you have a choice between being
with the resistance or being with hitler
i'm not saying he's like hitler
i'm just saying that he's on the side of
the people who are on the side of hitler
oh well oh then i guess i wasn't
comparing i guess i wasn't comparing he
knows exactly what he said but he thinks
that he can just bluster rage his way
through this thing
by the way whatever happens all those
complaints about the attacks on the free
press
you know philip what do you even read in
in english english language i sometimes
talk in using my
brains
it's just incredible
okay and then believe it or not
he got even worse
so way back before the gulf war
there was a person named april glasby
april gillespie worked for the state
department under james baker in the h.w
bush administration
and there is a widely controversial
meeting that she had with saddam hussein
and the government of iraq right before
the gulf war
in which she apparently said that the
united states had no interest in arab
versus arab conflicts the united states
really had no interest in air versus
their border conflicts and uh and that
we we just hope that they settled things
between iraq and kuwait
and it was widely reported just after
the gulf war that this had had an impact
on the thinking of the iraqi military
that the iraqi military had taken that
to mean that the united states would not
intervene in the case of an amer of an
iraqi invasion
of kuwait
now as it turns out that may may not
have been true right we don't know
whether the iraqis looked at april
glasby's comments and they thought okay
well we can go into kuwait or whether it
had no impact on their thinking
we also don't know exactly what you said
because all you have are sort of
contemporaneous records that were taken
in writing at the time however one thing
we do know is what joe biden said at a
public press conference in front of the
entire world yesterday
which is he said to vladimir putin about
ukraine just the tip
that is what he said to vladimir putin
yesterday at a press conference
he said you can go into ukraine so long
as it's just the tip
it's amazing
truly incredible we'll get to that in
just one moment by the way vladimir
putin has to be licking his shops china
has to be licking his chops there's a
reason that that russia china iran are
holding joint naval exercises now
there's a reason for that they're
looking at this administration and they
are thinking man if i'm going to make a
move now is the time to make it if
you're china looking with hungry eyes of
taiwan why would you not make that move
exactly if you know you're going to have
to
use military force at some point why not
do it now
while the well the getting is good
well this dunder head is in office
we'll get some more on this in just one
second first now is the time to lower
your mortgage rate like right now not
later the fed is going to start tapering
the rates are going to go up if you're
looking to refi your mortgage now is the
best time because the rates are still
low head on over to american financing
america's home for home loans you'll get
a free mortgage review from a salary
based mortgage consultant so you can
learn about custom loan options before
moving forward no pressure no obligation
no upfront or hidden fees just a simple
conversation around your financial goals
and the many ways they can save you up
to a thousand bucks a month think about
that for a second you could save up to
twelve thousand dollars a year and tens
of thousands long term simply by
refinancing your mortgage if you start
right now you might close in as fast as
10 days call 866
866-721-3300 that is
866-721-3300 or visit
americanfinancing.net and mls 182-334
nmls consumer access dot org your
biggest monthly bill is undoubtedly your
mortgage why not get that lowered if you
can right now they have all sorts of
options for you to think about head on
over to americanfinancing.net or give
them a call at
866-721-3300 alrighty in just one second
we'll get to joe biden offering ukraine
up to russia on a platter yesterday it's
it's incredible this guy he is the worst
president in american history and he is
one year in my god first the first
gathering of my book club 8 p.m eastern
7 pm central tonight i am pumped i've
been wanting to do this for years i
really want to read books with you guys
i want to go through your questions i
want to talk about some of my favorite
books tonight we are discussing george
orwell's famous dystopian novel 1984. so
grab your copy head on over to
dailywire.com and join me in tonight's
discussion right now you get 25 off a
daily wire membership with code 1984
over at dailywire.com
subscribe that's dailywire.com subscribe
use code 1984 for 25 off i'm pumped to
hang out and discuss orwell with you
tonight 8pm eastern 7 pm central be
there or be square you're listening to
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast and radio show in the nation
[Music]
alrighty so we finally get to the apex
of the insanity of joe biden's two-hour
press conference yesterday now aside
from the babbling incoherence aside from
his idiocy on the economy aside from his
idiosyncrovid
aside from the utter craziness of the
president of the united states openly
saying that all future elections are
corrupt unless he gets what he wants
which is a wild statement it really is
okay then we got to joe biden and russia
and ukraine so russia has 100 000 troops
stationed on the border of ukraine
they've been threatening ukraine for at
this point weeks and weeks and weeks
they've been essentially setting up
false flag operations inside ukraine as
an excuse for them to cross the border
of ukraine they've been attempting to
dictate to nato that ukraine should
never become a part of nato they've been
attempting to suggest that the west
should not come to ukraine's defense
and the west so far has been
extraordinarily tepid the west has done
pretty much nothing germany stopped the
united states from shutting down
preemptively nordstrom 2.
europe has prevented the united states
from from getting involved in sanctions
activity and the united states has
refused to put any sort of troop
presence in ukraine to even deter the
russians the goal here is not to go to
war with russia the goal is to deter
russia from going to war with ukraine
on a fundamental level i don't
understand why people don't get to turns
what deterrence is is we are going to
station some of our naval assets in the
black sea to say to the russians that if
you cross this line you must know there
will be consequences joe biden has not
done any of those things he's putting
additional troops in like poland
anyway
joe biden's foreign policy section of
his press conference last night began
with his defense of afghanistan so first
of all let's just be clear afghanistan
is one of the worst foreign policy
disasters in america's history i would
say it is the worst foreign policy
disaster in america's history
it is worse than vietnam it is worse
than vietnam because we voluntarily
pulled out of a country and collapsed it
in favor of 8th century barbarians for
no reason whatsoever none just because
joe biden wanted some sort of rhetorical
flourish so you could say he entered a
20-year war and currently there are 19
million women who are now living in
abject sex slavery essentially you have
people who are selling their own
children for food
that is not an exaggeration they are
literally selling small children in sex
slavery for food in afghanistan right
now they have terror groups that are
regrouping 13 american service people
were killed we have hundreds of
americans still stuck behind enemy lines
over there and have been stuck for
months at this point
we have the chinese taking advantage of
the rare earth's minerals in afghanistan
the russians celebrating because they
were backing the taliban
and here's joe biden declaring it all a
success yesterday
there is no way
to get out of afghanistan after 20 years
easily
not possible no matter when you did it
had we stayed
and i had not pulled those troops out we
would be asked to put somewhere between
20 and 50 000 more troops back in
because the only reason more americans
weren't being killed than others is
because the last president signed an
agreement to get out by may the first
and so it's all trump's fault okay so
that is the predicate for russia getting
more militant china getting more
militant all of our enemies see that
this president is a weakling and so
they've moved and putin is moving so
here is a joe biden yesterday saying
that he guesses that probably putin will
move into ukraine i mean why not he
probably has to says joe biden
i'm not so sure he has
certain what he's going to do my guess
is he will move in
he has to do something
he has to do something and now later
biden tries to back off that maybe we
don't know yet maybe he'll do something
maybe he won't but but he has to do my
guess is he will move mike
why not just give him the green light
okay it gets worse it gets worse so joe
biden is trying to explain that there
will be consequences if vladimir putin
goes into ukraine
but
he says that if vladimir putin does not
go full bore into ukraine like he
doesn't march into kiev
if he's if you just go if it's just the
tip
then it's fine
just the tip isn't isn't really isn't
really an in it's kind of a minor
incursion it's like a minor incursion
you know like bill clinton and monica
lewinsky minor incursion
here here is joe biden
opening i mentioned april glaspie before
the secret the under secretary of state
in the middle east during the the h.w
bush administration who suggested that
the united states might not do anything
if iraq invaded kuwait
and there's controversy over whether she
basically precipitated the iraqi
invasion or not if vladimir putin
invades ukraine
you can attribute it to this comment
above all others this is the president
of the united states in a full public
press conference saying that as long as
vladimir putin only commits a minor
incursion there might not be
consequences here was joe biden
yesterday
i think what you're going to see
is that
russia will be held accountable if it
invades and it depends on what it does
it's one thing if it's a minor incursion
and then we end up having to fight about
what to do and not do etc
it's one thing it's a minor incursion
it's one thing it's a it's a minor
incursion not just welcome just open the
gate man
and by the way according to cnn the the
entire government of ukraine is now in a
state of full-scale
meltdown panic because that is joe biden
just offering ukraine up on a platter
because vladimir putin is going to say
well what if it's not a minor incursion
first of all there's no such thing as a
minor incursion on american territory if
mexico just walked across the southern
border of the united states and took
over some of the border counties of of
texas
but they didn't take all of texas just
just like a little bit would we consider
that a minor like in what circumstances
is it considered a minor incursion for
any country to cross the sovereign
border of another country militarily
how does that even work
how is that a minor like that's that's
crazy towns what he is saying you know
sudetenland minor incursion
when in human history has it been
considered a minor incursion to just
cross the border of another sovereign
state
but there's joe biden saying by the way
he doubled down on this he was asked
again later to clarify and what he said
was you know nato's divided we can't get
the europeans on board to do anything if
it's a minor incursion so you know we
really i can't really say that we're
going to do much over here because you
know if he takes the nuts then he takes
the nuts you know like
to say that out loud in a press
conference in front of the world like
vladimir putin must just be laughing his
ass off at this weakling
so this necessitated the nightmares
gensake coming in
after presumably downing all of her
edibles that she keeps for emergency
circumstances
according to red seas over twitter
it necessitated her showing up
and releasing a statement here is the
statement quote president biden has been
clear with the russian president if any
russian military forces move across the
ukrainian border that's a renewed
invasion and it will be met with a swift
severe and united response from the
united states and our allies president
biden also knows from long experience
that the russians have an extensive
playbook of aggression short of military
action including cyber attacks and
paramilitary tactics and he affirmed
today that those acts of russian
aggression will be met with a decisive
reciprocal and united response no he did
precisely the opposite
he did exactly the opposite we played
the tape of it
it's fun to watch history being
rewritten in real time he literally said
yesterday nato is not united nato is
divided he literally said yesterday that
a minor incursion might be different
than a major full-scale russian invasion
that is joe biden giving a green light
to like putin would be an idiot not to
walk across the border at this point
why wouldn't he
seriously what what is the downside for
vladimir putin what are you gonna do to
him joe you can't get the germans on
board to sanction nordstrom too
not over a minor in christian it's um
incredible stuff okay so here's the
bottom line joe biden's presidency is
failing on every conceivable level which
leaves him one option that option is to
complain about republicans so now he's
trying to blame republicans he has a
majority in the senate he's a majority
in the house he's the president of the
united states he can't get anything done
because he decided to pursue a
completely partisan insane agenda
it has failed in every respect
naturally that means he's going to blame
republicans good luck with this pitch
i did not anticipate that there'd be
such a
stalwart effort to make sure
that the most important thing was that
president biden didn't get anything done
think about this what are republicans
for what are they for
they need one thing they're for alrighty
you ready here are a few things that
republicans are for they are for lower
taxes lower regulations not shutting
down the entire country because of your
idiotic coveted protocols they against
vax mandates by the way being against
the thing is also being for another
thing okay being against fax mandates
being means being for personal freedom
being against your garbage spending
plans means being in favor of a free
market economy being against your
foreign policy means being in favor of a
muscular american foreign policy
trying to blame republicans for your own
failures i love this he's like who could
have foreseen i don't know i never
thought that republicans might have
really you've been in the senate since
the senate didn't exist he's been in the
senate since 1622.
and this guy didn't it never occurred to
him that as president of the united
states he might run into some political
opposition it's incredible okay so
here's the bottom line failed president
failed administration no ability to turn
things around and he happens to be a
babbling incoherent fool that's where we
are
good luck we have three more years of
this gang all right we'll be back here
later today with an additional hour of
content in the meantime go check out the
matt wall show it airs at 1 30 pm
eastern if you haven't seen matt's
performance on dr phil it's uh it's
pretty spectacular we have some clips
that are available right now over on the
twitters be sure to check out matt's
show today over at dailywire.com i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro
[Music]
show the ben shapiro show is produced by
elliot feld executive producer jeremy
boring our supervising producer is
mathis glover and our production manager
is pavo wydowski associate producer
bradford carrington editing is by adam's
high events audio is mixed by mike
coromina hair and makeup is by fabiola
cristina production assistant jessica
crand the ben shapiro show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2022.
on the matt wall show we talk about the
things that matter real issues that
affect you your family our country not
just politics but culture faith current
events all the fundamentals if they
matter to you come check out the show